former Secretary of State Madeleine
Albright says countries must work
together in order to stop the
coronavirus the first woman to lead the
State Department says working separately
will only do more damage in her new book
hell and other destinations she writes
about her world wind career and why
retirement has never been an option she
joins us from her home in Washington DC
Madam Secretary good morning thanks for
being with us great to be with you thank
you you wrote in an op-ed piece in in
Time magazine that the world needs a
coordinated decisive response to the
virus but we're having trouble getting
States to they're competing just to buy
medical surprised with each other
how do we create a global coordinated
response to this well I think it's
absolutely essential because the virus
knows no boundaries and it's not easy I
think that as I write in my book I talk
a little bit about world war two and
what happened afterwards and I think we
need to figure out a way to strengthen
our international system I know that
there are people who don't like the word
globalization but it's not a four-letter
word I think that what we need to do is
figure out how we can help each other
because as I said the virus doesn't know
borders and I've talked about the fact
that people and institutions in the 70s
need a little refurbishing and the UN is
at its 75th anniversary and we need to
be supportive of it and get our act
together what I find interesting is that
their stories today actually about the
International Monetary Fund and the
World Bank talking about how they can be
helpful in other countries because that
is the place that is now in many ways
under the most threat because they don't
have the systems to deal with this and
so I think we have to work with each
other and not see things as zero-sum
games you write in the book that that
still almost every day you you imagine
yourself in in your successors shoes as
head of the State Department if
if you were Mike Pompeo today what would
you be doing well I would remember that
the main job of the Secretary of State
is diplomacy that diplomacy requires you
to put yourself into the other country's
shoes into the other people's shoes and
try to find some kind of compromise
solutions
I am hoping very much that we're not
quite clear how much he is traveling or
what he's doing but I do think that that
is the main job of Secretary of State
and then I have to say I'm deeply
troubled by the kinds of things I've
been hearing that have been going on in
the State Department because you can't
do diplomacy without diplomats and the
people in the department I found to be
very smart very dedicated and I'm very
troubled that we're not really keeping a
lot of them and defending them frankly
so that's what I would be doing do you
think there's any security risk to
reopening the country before we really
get a handle on the crisis well I do
think that from everything that I've
seen is clearly the sheltering and the
lack of contact social distancing in the
United States has made a difference and
I think that we shouldn't really be
overly eager to open up again until we
know have are clearer about what the
whole testing issue is and how we are
working together and I do know that
there kind of arguments going on at the
moment about who's really in charge you
really need a especially when you have a
variety of issues on health programs and
on helping small businesses the central
government our government does have a
role there's no question about it
but I think we need need to also
understand those that are closer to the
people the governors and the mayors and
to really coordinate you my I have
several mottos I mean I believe in
resiliency I believe in optimism and I
believe in working together and that's
what we have to be doing as we look
forward
or I met him secretary thank you so much
for being with us he'll and other
destinations is on sale today